it's great to welcome to the program
today michael cohen michael is the
former personal attorney to donald trump
also author of the book disloyal a
memoir and host of the maya culpa
podcast it's really great having you on
i appreciate it oh it's good to see you
david how you doing pal i'm doing well
um last time you and i spoke was on your
program and you said two things that
were interesting i'm wondering if you if
you still feel the same way uh one was
you do believe that ultimately donald
trump is going to be indicted and two
that you do not think that he is going
to run for president in in 2024 that was
a few months ago do you still feel the
same way
yeah i actually do uh nothing has
changed other than the greater american
grift by donald and cohorts
whereby you know their whole intent is
to make you believe that they're going
to run in 2024 because the second that
they tell you that we're not that's when
the spigot of funds from all of these
republican fools that are standing
behind donald will end up shutting off
um what is the that is that the only
reason to keep the grift going right now
that he may run just to keep fundraising
is that all there is to it
yeah otherwise what else is there for
him he knows he's not running because he
can't afford to lose a second time you
see again the big lie is only promoted
by the notion that the election was
stolen from him if in fact the election
was not stolen from him what happens to
the big lie you can't say in 2024 oh
they stole it from me again it's almost
like holy sh right quite frankly they
did it to us again they did it again and
it just doesn't work anymore the first
time you know like the old expression
first time shame on you second time
shame on me well this one would be a
shame on me moment and donald can't
afford that and statistically he already
knows that he can't win the general
election
on the criminal stuff
who's going to charge him and for what
crimes i think is the most common
question i get when the topic of that
comes up what what are the answers to
those questions well it makes it makes
sense david that that's the number one
question that comes to you it happens to
be the number one question that
everybody keeps asking me
unfortunately you know i don't discuss
the summon substance of the district
attorney uh or the attorney general's
case here in new york um the things that
we do know is that it's predicated upon
valuation of assets uh using those
valuations for loans and other things
but there's also then the second half
which is the devaluation of the
identical as
for tax purpose
okay so
without getting into detail about your
involvement it's not the obstruction
stuff that people are talking about
during the presidency it's these are
we're talking about financial stuff here
from the business
well that's what we're talking about
with the district attorney the district
attorney in the state of new york would
have absolutely no jurisdiction over the
january sixth insurrection that's
clearly federal
um when you uh i mean just for context
for people who may or may not know i
mean you had a long history of
supporting democratic candidates for a
very long time right i mean how do you
define your personal politics
david i've been a democrat my entire
life in 1987
i worked for congressman joe moakley of
massachusetts uh while i was attending
american university uh i have
been a democrat my entire life until
ultimately i was required
to switch parties
during the
campaign because actually i should say
post the campaign
because
i was the first
democrat who held the position as vice
chair of the rnc finance committee and
they just couldn't accept that i mean it
makes perfect sense yeah and so they
said we can't have a democrat running
the finance committee for those yeah
well yeah fortunately for them it was
being run by steve nguyen who just did a
remarkable job in terms of fundraising
it was steve wynn myself it was elliot
broidy and lou dejoy right it was really
the four of us and obviously they
couldn't have a democrat on that
that team
so in the last 24 to 48 hours we heard
about these text messages that were
allegedly sent to the former chief of
staff mark meadows on the day of the
january sixth insurrection it included
laura ingraham the fox news host texting
meadows and saying this is looking
really bad hey david david i'm sorry do
we pronounce it is it ingram or is it
ingraham i mean i've heard people say
both personally i can't stand her either
way i don't care i don't care how you
pronounce the last thing i'm just trying
to to you know get an expert meaning
yourself i'm trying to get an expert
analysis on this i've said ingraham and
people say that that's not correct
because i heard it i hear it as ingraham
i hear this ingram i like i said i can't
stand her either way it doesn't make a
difference to me but i just want to at
least pronounce the name right so she
was texting mark meadows on the sixth
sean hannity was texting don jr instead
of texting his dad was texting mark
meadows
for me the most interesting thing about
those text messages
is that the story that they told after
about it might have been antifa and
it it was really no big deal they
obviously knew on january 6 that it was
trump supporters that were there what
else do you make of the fact that so
many people from fox were texting mark
meadows as this was going on
are you shocked is there anything about
that question that shocks you that fox
and newsmax and oann wouldn't be [ __ ]
lying about this
seriously i mean for god's sakes the
whole thing again is a it was an
insurrection and what we know now as a
direct result is that
1787
187 minutes transpired before dear old
donald came out and said hey i want
everybody to disperse go home and that's
because he had his fun over those three
hours watching these these
mega fools running around in
paramilitary gear right beating up on
police officers
out there with these massive maga flags
and trump 2020 and you know god knows
what other stupid swanky swag [ __ ] that
they thought that they were wearing
running around all right for the benefit
of who their fuhrer donald and for some
unknown reason the guy sat there in the
in the white house in our house
watching the ship television and
thinking that it was okay that this is
good that he's going to somehow stop the
electoral decision process from
declaring joe biden as the as the
president of the united states and that
somehow he would be reinserted as
president of the united states for
another four years despite the fact that
he lost by close to
9 million votes
and that the electoral count was at
absolute air speeding
the um the stories from that day are
that all sorts of people were urging him
do this do this do that and that he was
ignoring it at least for a while
when you were working for him was that a
common occurrence where you would go and
say this is not good for you we need to
do abc and that he would just ignore it
on the idea that he knows more than you
do
right so donald knows more than
everybody let's just look back because
everything with the reason why i'm so
successful in predicting donald trump's
stupidity is because first and foremost
i graduated um valedictorian from trump
university all right that's first and
foremost second it's because nothing
with him is original it's all like a
regurgitation of past [ __ ] coming out so
yes
donald trump does not listen to anyone
donald trump knows more than everyone
let's look at some of the things that he
said he knows more about epidemiology
though he didn't use the word because he
doesn't know the word nor can he spell
it but he knows more about science than
the scientists again referring at that
point in time to epidemiologist
extraordinaire dr anthony fauci in the
covid virus he knew more about it what
else does dear old douchebag donald know
more about he knows more about military
and strategy than our
generals i mean if you're not scratching
your head at this point while watching
the show and saying come on seriously
the [ __ ] out of here already you know
more about seemingly everything
than anybody else and yet you're an
expert in nothing
right why don't we talk about being
since you know so much how trump vodka
do how trump mortgage do right how did
you know trump's stakes do how did
trump's suits do how did trump anything
do the brand is worthless because truth
be told he showed himself for what he
really is and i say it all the time he's
a racist sexist misogynistic xenophobic
homophobic islamophobic anti-semitic
germaphobe
that's who he is and so how you could
expect
that this is going to be the guy that
knows more about everybody and
everything it's just not true in fact
what do we know he's ignorant and he's
arrogant
hey on the ante just to pick one one of
those 10 things on the anti-semitism
stuff
you know um you were his personal lawyer
for a while his daughter converted to
judaism his son-in-law is jewish his
grandkids from from them are are jewish
there's sometimes these there there are
people i've met
who harbor anti-semitic beliefs but they
sort of want to be in league with jews
for lightly anti-semitic reasons like
they think they're clever like the
saudis for example now are very
interested in doing business with uh
certain um uh hedge funds that are run
by jewish individuals can you talk a
little bit about the seeming
inconsistence between the number of
jewish folks in his family and what you
believe to be his anti-semitism
okay first of all in order to sort of
care
about
the jewish people in order to care about
forget about his workers right myself
alan weiselberg alan garton larry glick
and a whole slew of other individuals at
the trump organization in high-ranking
positions right being jewish he doesn't
care
if you're able to accomplish what he
needs he wouldn't care what race
religion well actually he wouldn't care
what religion that you are but yes he
does find jews to be clever and so that
was something his father taught him you
know that they're okay if you work for
him now as far as ivanka you know be um
obviously becoming jewish i'm converting
um you know
now being uh what do you call it you you
know orthodox but modern orthodox
having the three you know jewish
grandchildren why donald trump doesn't
care because in order to care about
somebody else's religion you have to
care about your own and donald trump
does not care about his own religion
because he had no religious upbringing
nor does that you know when he turns
around and he's holding the bible it's
another lie and he says i know more
about you know corinthian you know
corinthian 2 and so i mean
it
the guy
never went to church the guy went to
church for maybe his um confirmation and
then stopped but he doesn't have
religious convictions therefore when
people say to me oh but his grandkids
are jewish so clearly he can't be
anti-semitic
it's the stupidest comment that somebody
can make you can't care about you know
about christianity if you don't care
about your own religion you can't care
about islam uh if you don't care about
your own religion that's just a fact he
has no religious conviction at all could
care less not just about his grandkids
uh or his daughter's religion but he
doesn't care about his daughter or his
grandkids either
um wow
okay by the way
he didn't give a [ __ ] about his own
children throughout his entire life
let's just let me just back it up with
facts something that i continuously do
despite the fact some people want to
hear it and those that do already
despise the [ __ ] guy anyway and those
that don't
again would allow him to shoot someone
on fifth avenue and get away with it
he walked out on his three children
that's okay many people get divorced i
get it he walked out on them but he
basically had little to nothing to do
with them he was an absentee father
all along don then from you know went to
the hill after hill school then ivanka
went away to boarding school came back
uh then eric as soon as that he was old
enough went off to boarding school as
well he you know then he has tiffany
from marla sends her off to california
barely sees her maybe once a year on her
birthday they speak all of a sudden now
it's daddy daddy daddy oh i loved him he
was such a great father that's not the
she used to tell all of her friends
right and now you have baron when was
the last time you saw baron when was the
last time like in if if i was president
of the united states i'd be throwing a
baseball with my kid right because
that's my son's sport right or we'd be
tossing around a football
i would probably even build a tennis
court in the backyard so my son and i
could hit or my daughter and so when you
see my children you never see baron
anywhere he barely has anything to do
with that child either right i mean now
all of a sudden he's going to worry
about his grandkids donald trump doesn't
care about anyone or anything other than
himself period drop the mic uh michael
last thing i want to talk about because
this has been the source of such
controversy
you were a character in the infamous
steel dossier
and specifically in the dossier the
allegation was
you went to prague
you met
with either or both russian officials or
those who hacked the dnc and you were
involved there now you've said it's it's
not even a distortion it's just not true
you you've never been to prague right
i've never been to prague i've never
been to anywhere in the czech republic i
don't even believe you know um because
my geography is not great but you know
they claimed that i came into prague
through germany i've never been to
germany in fact david i've never even
been to russia
and so do you know why that ended up in
the dossier aside from anything else
being true or false do you even know the
origin of that
yeah so the steele.ca as it relates to
me and everybody says well there are
things in the steel dossier that are
accurate or potentially accurate thereby
therefore we can't discount it
completely and i say that's fair that's
fair for you to say but let me only
bring up the 11 allegations raised about
me more like anybody else none of them
are accurate it's [ __ ]
christopher steele is a
joke as an mi6 agent who supposedly had
contacts and you know had information
and knowledge um that was relevant to
this christopher steele's a joke the mi6
should be embarrassed of this document
they should be embarrassed that he ever
worked for them it's just absolutely
untrue i have said it since day number
one it has been proven by the fbi that i
was never there right you may even
recall that i somewhere along the line
somebody put out oh it was another
michael cohen that was there and so but
yet they could never produce that
michael cohen's passport i just wasn't
there in fact where was i i was in los
angeles california with my family with
my son who was looking to play baseball
as a pitcher for usc trojans and we met
with the entire coaching staff he was
being looked at and so you know i know
for a fact that you can't be in two
places at once and i don't have a twin
brother so you know i don't even know
where this came from and yet
it was just used and promoted on and on
and on because this of course would have
been a big deal now some of the things
that i testified before the house
oversight committee as well as to the
select committees of intelligence by
both the house the senate and other
committees and other law enforcement
agencies
was that
i was never in prague however however
the dissemination of the podesta emails
i testified that came from roger stone
in a phone call why that was never
follow through i don't know the answer
it's so
infuriating when i see now that now that
you know democrats have the house right
um
meaning the white house
put the attorney general merrick garland
onto it
roger stone contacted donald i was there
he put it on the speaker box and he said
nothing shy of in a couple that i just
got off the phone with um what what's
his name uh
uh from from uh with wikileaks julian
assange with julian assange and
in a couple of days there's going to be
a massive dump of emails that's going to
destroy the clinton campaign and donald
was like okay that's great that's great
right then after when he hung up on
roger you said to me you believe it i
said listen roger's a [ __ ] artist
right it's why of course you call them
the dirty trickster but listen with
roger you never know and lo and behold
was it two three days later massive dump
of podesta's emails did it hurt
hillary's campaign it sure did did it
destroy it no i don't think it destroyed
it but it was every single thing that
roger stone stated
make sure you listen to michael cohen's
podcast the maya culp podcast the book
is disloyal a memoir michael i really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much for doing it
david really good to see you and stay
stay safe out there